hey youtubers is Charlie if you guys
didn't know Emilia Clarke from Game of
Thrones was cast in the Star Wars han
solo film as the female lead so this is
gonna be my reaction video I'll explain
what's going on in how this is going to
affect Game of Thrones Season eight so
if you heard about this the other day
you might have noticed that nobody was
talking about who she is playing because
Lucasfilm is keeping that really close
to the vest I think for one big reason
is that it's some big change from the
established canon like they said that
they got rid of the EU or most of the EU
so that they could do new things with
the film's that means that she might be
playing a character that we've never
seen before like a completely original
character or she might be a recast
younger version of a character that we
already know really well like Princess
Leia but I don't think that's the case I
think the whole idea with this Han Solo
film is to tell the story of how he won
the Millennium Falcon from a Lando
Calrissian who's being played by Donald
Glover but - I think they're also trying
to tell the story of how he and
Chewbacca came together and the story of
how Chewbacca came to have the life-debt
but largely the story of how Han Solo
won the Millenium Falcon was in a sabaki
game
so imagine James Bond in a Smuggler's
version of Casino Royale playing that
epic poker game but he winds up winning
the Falcon because Lando doesn't have
enough to cover his bets but the story
of how Chewbacca came to be Han Solo's
copilot of the money of Falcon the story
of the life debt they might weave in a
lot of Clone Wars stuff because
technically Clone Wars is still canon to
Star Wars they didn't throw that out
like they threw the rest of the EU out
so once we get some more details we can
talk a little bit more about that but
what about Game of Thrones because
Emilia Clarke if she's gonna be the
female lead of this Han Solo movie they
start shooting in January what does that
save for Game of Thrones season a well
the good news is that it shouldn't have
any effect at all because of winter so
on Game of Thrones this past season one
of the big problems filming was they had
to wait for things to get colder because
in the world of Game of Thrones winter
has come so they need to reflect that in
all the filming that they do so they
just waited till later in the year till
it was actually winter in some of the
places they were filming
Europe so typically what they've done in
previous seasons is they just start
shooting during the summer and they'd
shoot all the way up towards the end of
November early December so this year
they waited a couple more months filmed
a little bit later in the year but
they'd still be done filming for her to
do Han Solo in January and even though
it could take up to six months to film a
really big Star Wars film she would
still be done in time to start filming
Game of Thrones season 8 on time just
keep in mind that they're gonna be doing
the exact same thing next year with
season 8 they'll start filming later in
the year there'll be fewer episodes so
they won't film quite as much but each
of the episodes that they film will be
much bigger so that's like a whole other
video about them filming season 8
because it will be hardcore winter by
the time that starts but emilia clarke
in a Star Wars movie this is a huge deal
I would say of all the Game of Thrones
actors that I would love to see in a
Star Wars film she's somewhere near the
middle I feel like Lena Headey is a
better actress but the thing is is this
is a movie about a younger Han Solo like
a 20-something Han Solo if you imagine
that he's like a 30-something Han Solo
when the original trilogy picks up so
you have to cast an actress that has
like aged parody with Alton Ehrenreich
who's playing Han Solo so a lot of you
are wondering maybe this is Han Solo's
wife from before he met Princess Leia I
don't think that's who she's playing
because she's an african-american
character so I don't think they're gonna
whitewash that her name is sana stauros
another big thing on the fan wish list
is ahsoka in the movies a lot of you
were asking me maybe she's playing
ahsoka the thing about that is that I
think we'll eventually see her somewhere
in the spin-off films but I think it's
much more likely that ahsoka would show
up during the obi-wan spin-off film just
because she obi-wan invader go hand in
hand in han Solo
didn't really encounter that many Jedi
before he met Luke Adobe went on
Tatooine the story of the original
trilogy like you know when we get to
Episode seven he says the force it's all
true like it took him a long time to get
to that point I don't think there's
gonna be a lot of Jedi or even Darth
Vader in this Han Solo movie so my
thought is is that it's more likely that
she's a Jin or so
type character someone who's really big
but brand-new and original to this film
so let me know in the comments what do
you guys think about emilia clarke in
this star wars han solo movie and who do
you think that she is playing just you
know keep in mind that they're not doing
a lot of expanded universe stuff so
she's probably not one of those
characters and keep in mind that if
she's this age during this han solo
movie then she would also be like
princess leia age during Star Wars
Episode seven so she'd be like a really
old lady standing somewhere in the
background here if she's still alive in
the new films but as we learn more about
the film I'll do more videos so be sure
to subscribe for more Han Solo videos I
think people would be a little bit more
excited about the Han Solo film than
they are about rogue one just because of
the characters that they're doing like
they're doing the big characters so I
feel like the level of fascination is
just going to be that much greater
because you know even though stealing
the plans for the Death Star is a really
big deal most of the characters during
rogue one are actually pretty new so I
think the performance of rogue one at
the box-office
will largely determine how they tune the
other spin-off films like how much of
the old character should we put in these
other films which film should we be
doing like do we do a Yoda film do we do
a Boba Fett film do we do an obi-wan
film I actually think it's more likely
that they would do a Yoda film and
obi-wan Kenobi before they would do Boba
Fett just depending on the tone that
they want to go with but that's another
big thing which other big film do you
want them to do next because this Han
Solo movie will kind of fill the gap
between Star Wars Episode eight in
Episode nine so we'll get that next
spin-off film after episode Knight so
that's a long ways off they have a long
time to figure it out but I do feel like
obi-wan Kenobi would be like the solid
pick for like the next big film to do
but new Walking Dead posting later
tonight and then I'll do my Westworld
video just like last week it seems like
everybody was really happy with the
west-world video that I did so I'll keep
doing that through the rest of the
season so while you guys wait for that
to post you can click here for my Star
Wars Episode 8 video and you can click
here for all my Game of Thrones season 6
and season 7 videos thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight
you